Con-fi-nés
Vous connaissez tous ce célèbre stylo bille.
Il a été inventé par le Baron Bich en 1950…
Et nous nous sommes tous interrogés
sur l’utilité de ce petit trou.
Il permet à l’encre de s’écouler.
Quand la bille, située à la pointe du stylo
roule sur le papier, elle dépose de l’encre.
Mais pour laisser sa trace en continu,
elle doit s’enrober en permanence.
Si le stylo était hermétiquement fermé, comme ici,
l’air ne pourrait pas pénétrer à l’intérieur,
aucune pression ne s’exercerait sur la colonne d’encre pour la pousser jusqu’à la bille…
On ne pourrait pas écrire.
Pas même une « capsule de déconfiné ».
Grâce à ce petit trou, l’air
peut pénétrer à l’intérieur du stylo.
La pression est alors la même
à l’intérieur qu’à l’extérieur.
C’est la pression atmosphérique qui agit sur
la colonne d’encre… et la pousse jusqu’à la bille.
Si vous avez aimé cette capsule,
n’hésitez pas à laissé un pouce bleu
Vous pouvez également revoir celles des jours précédents en cliquant sur le côté, en haut ou en bas.
J’en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour.
Pour être sûr de ne pas en rater : abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche.
Allez à demain et n’oubliez pas :
nous sommes confinés mais on reste en lien.